I just made a person I used to call her
Moscow thinking of a new name I never
had a friend named Roscoe
[Music]
hey what up GQ is a bug with early hip
hoppers label and you on the rocks man
you already know me and what started
this was my first surgery right with a
big old qubit but the cube one was gold
and this was gold and then he's had some
diamonds after that but it wasn't with
the Cooper first you can't I got the
coop and think I had this it was it was
his piece ray and diamonds was not vvl
style like that he looked crazy we was
like this here it's an update on this
and bust down bus down bus now I must
down bus down [ __ ] it's a say boogies
made me look good at this I made my own
custom design with the surco I don't
like this chain on me today but I got a
Yankee Stadium on it the Yankee Stadium
you like a big painting me too as I grew
up right up clockmaking Stadium and then
I got to bridge on the other side the
block that I grew up on shocked at the
hybrids and EQ stadium on one chain
flooded and diamonds for me
that Park I was talking about at circle
harbor chain this could go all night oh
I could just pick this lock and attach
it so it with the resolution I don't got
a racket all heavy for me cuz that have
[ __ ] only ignore how much that's a
way but actually heavy
I got my name just from first of all I
watch the movie paid in full a million
times so just watch the night and people
a by 1/8 time one of my friends coming
to crib when I'm watching that movie so
I used to saying a buddy and it came
along that I started with hoodies a lot
in high school and I was like [ __ ]
and it's definitely it's gonna stand up
and game sure this day doctor I want you
out of this dream right I only got one
of my wings with me today this is uh
this is a disco ball right here snow
cone whatever you wanna call it is Iraq
my hero or just 13,000 right here I
never was really a big fan of rings I
like being able to move my things around
anything I spot more than with one ring
right now I got it for me
I've had some space I got another ring
just like this right here too but just
like how my females get dressed up and
they wear high heels in name and they
feel comfortable [ __ ]
same [ __ ] but is way different won't
even suffer that much is that you think
about it like it's not that bad I'm
satisfied I've bonded because like I put
it I put in hard work then when you look
at it it ain't everything
for me I think everything its father and
you got it you got it you got it you get
it just crazy because when I was younger
I never saw myself wearing jewelry like
that I always wore my little oopsie like
the Michael Cole white or a g-shot but I
never picture myself on a [ __ ] Patek
Phillipe for me be honest I'm tired of
this March I will because I like how it
fits my arm and like this is the perfect
fit for Mama go flat right on I'm only
like having too much big goofy stuff in
Russia so
it was a great part of my best man
and this lifestyle free pop hey I lit up
like all the attention is on me with
this lifestyle you need attention from
me so I don't like doing crazy [ __ ] so
this is like my Testament this Jewish is
a big dude man [ __ ] dance
[Music]